patience et multiplie ce matin dans la
ville après l'attentât qu'est-ce que
vous avez un certain michael mason des
mandats d'arrêt dans quatre états pour
escroquerie eh ben on va le show veille
discrètement hockey
ça sent pas très bon pour toi suis qu un
pickpocket j'ai volé le sac ne savais
pas qu'il y avait une bande des dents tu
dois être vraiment fort je suis le
meilleur
le l6 et 8 mois mon portefeuille il est
toujours là n'est pas l'argent en masse
à la bombe a été fabriqué par un
policier infiltré
votre mission est arrêté ça écoute
michael tu veux te racheter bosse pas
pour la cia à toi d'agir vous êtes
trompés d'adressé
tu devrais peut-être essayer de
maîtriser 14
vous êtes inconscients et irresponsables
vous ne pouvez pas débarquer métier dans
le tas
qui fait quoi maintenant tu es tout seul
n'a pas de plan personne pour te couvrir
je suis inconscient et irresponsable
je peux avoir un flan